et on continue C 78 avec notre nouvel
invité Jean-Pierre maillot bonsoir vous
êtes responsable formation au sein du
radio club amateur de 550tins en Yveline
et si vous êtes en plateau avec nous
c'est que le radio club de Saint-Quentin
mais ce n'est pas le seul organise une
journée porte ouverte samedi 22
septembre je dis tout de suite les
horaires 10h 18h dans vos locaux à
Montini pour justement présenter cette
activité et d'abord ma première question
qui va être une question de vraie
bécienne c'est la différence entre le
radio amateur et le cbiste alors le
cbiste lui peut acheter un appareil dans
le commerce qui sera normalement limité
en puissance il n'a droit qu'à quelques
fréquences il n'a pas de règles très
précises à respecter normalement il doit
déclarer sa station mais par contre il
est très contraint dans les plages de
fréquence possibles donc il ne peut pas
jouer avec la propagation ou d'autres
phénomènes comme c'est un accès
relativement libre ça rendu beaucoup de
service aux chauffeurs de camion pour
communiquer entre euxe ça qu' conna CBI
effectivement entreut bien entendu ça a
été un bon développement je pense que
c'est utile pour eux par contre on y
trouve de tout le meilleur et le pire
bon ça c'est pour les civiste on a bien
compris vous étiez passiviste et donc le
radio amateur lui c'est
R est beaucoup plus réglementé en fait
le radio amateur ça je dirais sa
fonction est définie par l'Union
internationale des télécommunications au
même titre que le le site mode de
fonctionnement des autres organismes que
ce soit l'aviation la marine radio
amateur tous les services la police par
exemple donc en fait vont sur les ondes
oui donc nous nous avons nos fréquences
vous avez vos fréquences c'est ça voilà
donc nous avons un certain nombre de
bandes de fréquences qui ont été
attribué aux amateurs pour service rendu
d'ailleurs dans les débuts où les
radioamateurs étaient pionniers
fabriquai du matériel ils ont démontré
qu'il était possible de communiquer à
travers l'Atlantique c'est les premiers
contacts à travers l'Atlantique sur onde
courte c'est radioamateur et ensuite
bien entendu tout le monde s'est
précipité c'était en quelle année par en
1823 d'acc en 1923 excusez-moi ah oui
d'accord euh donc ça a servi évidemment
pendant la deè guerre mondiale alors ça
a servi bien entendu en fait ça ça a
surtout débloqué tout le système radio
parce qu'on ne croyait pas à ces
fréquence au début c'est pour ça qu'on
les avait donné aux amateurs et en fait
ils ont montré que c'était utile et
qu'en plus on pouvait communiquer avec
des des puissances beaucoup plus faibles
alors c'est très réglementé vous l'avez
dit parce que il faut aussi un permis
pas si ça s'appelle un permis d'émettre
mais en tout cas il faut un permis condu
c'est un certificat CE s'appelle un
certificat d'opérateur radio ça se passe
auprès de l'Agence nationale des
fréquences on passe un examen qui
comporte deux sections une partie
réglementation une partie technique et
une fois qu'on a cet examen c'est
l'équivalent du comme vous l'avez dit du
permis de conduire donc là maintenant on
peut demander une licence donc une
autorisation de des mettes et
l'administration nous attribue un
indicatif qui est en en France c'est la
lettre F suivie d'un chiffre suivi de
trois lettres alors cet indicatif est
tout à fait personnel radio club en a un
moi j'en ai un chaque radioamateur en a
un d'accord il est donc personnel il est
donc tout à fait personnel d'accord et
vous qui êtes responsable de la
formation vous êtes celui qui fait
passer vous êtes monsieur le permisi
monsieur permis alors on ne fait pas
passer l'examen c'est vraiment
l'administration qui fait passer nous
préparons les les personnes qui sont
intéressées à cet examen donc sur la
partie technique un peu la
réglementation ou là c'est plus du
parkerur et on leur fait passer des
petits examens effectif on leur donne
tous les tuyaux qui vont bien pour leur
permettre de se préparer en général ça
se passe bien alors je l'ai dit il y a
des journées portes ouvertes qui sont
organisées par votre radio club de 50
ans en Eveline ce samedi 22 vous êtes
pas tout seul il y a 30 clubs en tout
radio club qui organise ça c'est une
première alors ce regroupement des radio
clubs dans en France entière he c'est un
peu une première de faire l'opération
porte ouverte le même jour est ce que
les radio club ont souhaité à cette
occasion c'est donner un peu plus de
visibilité en fait notre activité qui
est une activité quand même scientifique
est assez mal connu on a beauoup faire
des efforts pour et justement votre
activité vous dit est scientifique en
gros moi qui n'y connais pas grand-chose
c'est en fait vous communiquer avec
d'autres personnes via un émetteur alors
on communique avec d'autres personn
principal but c'est de communiquer avec
le monde entier ça peut être le
principal but en fait pour communiquer
il va falloir le matériel donc on peut
considérer que on peut avoir envie de
construire son matériel il faut des
antennes on peut avoir envie de
construire et de comprendre le
fonctionnement des antennes si on veut
fonctionner par en onde courte il va
falloir comprendre la propagation
comprendre la propagation c'est les tâes
solaires le flux solaire l'onosphère
donc vous voyez qu'il y a plein de
ramification ah oui c'est compliqué
quand même on peut aller très loin mais
on a le choix on n pas obligé pour
communiquer avec quel pas juste d'Acher
sa petite station et dans le micro en
fait on pourrait s'en contenter mais je
trouve un peu dommage il vaut mieux
aller un peu plus loin pendant que vous
parliez on a vu quelques images d'une
expérience qui était qui était
passionnante qui a duré pendant 1 an
enfin en tout cas vous avez mis un an
pour réparer tout cela c'était le
contact entre des des lycéens du lycée
d'cartes de Montini et puis la Station
spatiale internationale ça paraît fou
quand même alors ce qui est fou c'est
pas tellement le contact avec la station
spaciale qui est je te dirais c'est une
liaison qui devrait être facile ce qui
la complique c'est que le la station
spatiale n'est n pas à disposition des
amateurs ils ont une station amateur à
bord mais ils ont tellement d'occupation
très peu de temps donc les contacter
c'est difficile ensuite au sol il y
avait plus de 200 personnes qui
regardaient donc pas de faux pas donc il
a fallu préparer les choses parce qu'en
plus vous aviez le temps était vraiment
chronométré vous aviez un temps Ctait
c'était la minute moins de la minute ou
forcé hein puisque c'est une trajectoire
relativement rapide donc il faut saisir
le moment le satellite est là il n'est
plus là donc on a ce créneau alors il y
a des satellites radioamateurs qui
existent qui tournent autour de la Terre
et les radioamateurs une certaine
expérience de l'utilisation de ces
satellites donc c'est pas complètement
une découverte de de faire la même chose
avec ISS ISS ça se prépare par contre ça
fait rêver on va dire ça fait rêver et
puis surtout vous avez impliqué des
lycéens et ça c'est aussi une des
actions du radio club amateur de
Saint-Quentin c'est de vouloir
développer ces actions vers les
collégiens les lycéens alors ça c'est
important pour nous parce qu'en fait
c'est c'est là qu'on peut trouver la
génération suivante de radio amateur ici
en janvier nous avions Geoffrey qui est
un des lycéens de Descartes qui avait
fait le contact justement plateau qui
est venu au plateau et un un de ces un
autre élève est venu passer l'examen
après donc on a eu quand même d'autres
retombé j'en connais plusieurs qui sont
intéressés mais qui sont actuellement
plus en train de préparer des concours
donc bon mettre ça un petit peu sur la
touche
pour vous dites c'est une activité
scientifique qu quelle compéten il faut
pour pratiquer le radio alors par
nécessairement beaucoup de compéten il
faut d'abord être intéressé passionné
avoir envie d'apprendre parce que on est
comme tous on a on arrive on ne connait
pas tout
euh si on a déjà une expérience en
électronique évidemment tout est facile
même l'examen devient très facile il y a
juste la partie réglementation à
apprendre le reste on a déjà vu à
l'école ou dans les formations
professionnelles on
a la formation est un peu plus
compliquée si les personnes ne sont pas
dans le domaine technique électronique
j'entends mais on a formé des artisans
on a formé des Bou un boulanger bref des
personnes qui n'avaient pas du tout de
d'accès dans ce domaine c'est un peu
plus long ils doivent faire un peu plus
d'effort mais ils y arrivent sans
problème quand vous dites c'est un peu
plus long il faut faire plus d'effort
c'est qu' y a des des choses à apprendre
il y a des formules mathématiques à
apprendre ou des chosesah oui bien
entendu la loi d'hôme pour quelqu'un qui
a fait l'électricité c'est évident pour
quelqu'un qui l'a jamais vu et bien il
faut faut l' prendre donc en fait une
partie de de ce qui s'apprend en lycée
ou en étude technique par la suite ben
il faut y passer que au moment où on
communique en fait dans un micro avec
une station dans le monde entier ça ça
dure quelques instants c'est peut-être
l'aboutissement mais il y a tout un
travail de préparation
avant
conruction création en tout cas de sa
petite station alors création de la
station c'est facultatif on peut qu' l'
mentionné tout à l'heure on peut acheter
créer c'est parce que on aura on sera
intéressé par cette partie technique
mais le je dirais pour l'examen c'est
incontournable il faut passer un certain
nombre de faut répondre à un certain
nombre de questions on doit prendre
cette partie là après on peut l'oublier
et puis faire du trafic et certains ne
retournent plus dans la technique mais
ils vont être très actifs en contact
contacter des stations lointaines
travailler par satellite réflexion sur
la lune et quand vous DZ justement
contacter des stations lointaines est-ce
que vous avez des des souvenirs
d'échanges avec des pays incroyables où
on a c'est difficile d'accéder alors
souvenir d'échange moi je dirais mon
souvenir c'est pas une station très
lointaine c'était nos communications
sont très réglementées donc on n' pas le
droit normalement de transmettre des
communications privé par exemple sauf
catastrophe et c'était au Liban pendant
la guerre du Liban j'avais dans mon dans
mon entreprise un collègue qui était
libanais et dans la famille était au
Liban et qu'il n'arrivait plus à joindre
par téléphone donc l'international était
coupé j'ai fait un certain nombre de
veille et j'ai réussi à contacter un
amateur qui était pas loin et par
téléphone il a pu joindre la famille
d'accord j'ai enregistré ça et là j'ai
fait un mais je dirais c'est mon c'est
certainement mon meilleur souvenir à la
fois c'est c'est quand même un souvenir
émouvant du coup c'est un souvenir
émouvant l'avoir réussi ça m'a vraiment
fait quelque chose mais j'en ai pas fait
énormément de grandes distances de
grandes performances en fait
personnellement d'utr en fond vous vous
êtes plus technicien je suis un peu plus
technicien mais une une dernière
question sur ces journées portes
ouvertes qu'est-ce qu'on va pouvoir
découvrir donc le 22 septembre entre 10h
et 18h alors entre 10h et 18h nous
aurons un des guides qui vont permettre
aux visiteurs de découvrir nos
installations bien entendu nous aurons
des opérateurs radio qui vont faire du
trafic donc on va pouvoir voir comment
ça se passe quels sont les protocole les
ce qu'on fait nous aurons une station
qui sera dédiée satellite qui permettra
peut-être pas de travailler à travers
les satellites parce que là il faut bien
tous les satellites ne sont pas actifs
il faut avir être dans le bon créneau
mais on peut écouter souvent les balises
des satellites qui transportent des
informations nous aurons également des
vidéos dont le vidéo Haris on est quand
même assez fier et puis la présentation
des activités du club nous avons un
petit musée donc nous ferons nous
montrerons ces pièces qui vont de 1910 à
peu près jusqu'à notre époque ah bah
très bien très bien mais merci en tout
cas beaucoup Jean-Pierre maillot d'être
venu sur le plateau nous présenter à la
fois cette activité de radio club
amateur et puis les journées portes
ouvertes qui donc ont lieu le samedi 22
septembre dans votre club entre 10h et
18h an merci beaucoup d'être d'être venu
allez on va continuer ce 78 avec un
sujet qui est aussi lié à la technologie
aujourd'hui vous surfez depuis n'importe
quel endroit via la wifi et bien
imaginez demain que ces données ne
soient plus véhiculé par les ondes
électromagnétiques mais par la lumière
des chercheurs de l'Université de
Versailles Saint-Quentin ont imaginé ce
système on
regarde que la lumière soit bien mieux
que la lampe d'alaldin les génies du
Laboratoire d'Ingénierie des systèmes de
versaill de l'université versaill
SaintQuentin ont imaginé un système
permettant de transférer des
informations numériques via le spectre
lumineux par exemple sur de l'audio vous
avez donc un lecteur MP3 un lecteur MP3
après c'est des données numériques c'est
du 01 donc qu'est-ce qu'on va faire on
va faire communiter ce qu'on appelle
l'éclairage à let c'est comme si on
éteignait on allumait à des fréquences
très rapides vous à des fréquences
variées et du coup bah vous véhiculez
comme ça les informations les données
les 01 de l'autre côté vous avez un
photorécepteur et il retranscode et
redécode cette information là pour
rransformer ça en une musique c'est
exactement le même principe que sur du
Wii avec un avantage aucune émission
d'onde électromagnétique sur 5 500000 €
ont été investis pour développer cette
technologie peu onéreuse selon ses
concepteurs les scientifiques de ce
laboratoire travaillent désormais au
sein d'une start-up destiné à la
commercialisation du produit une société
dont l'UVSQ pourrait bien devenir
actionnaire
côté client plusieurs grandes
entreprises se sont déjà montré
intéressé comme la SNCF ou encore
Philips le musée gréin de Montréal au
Québec a déjà fait l'acquisition pour
400000 € de plusieurs tablettes équipées
de cette technologie des lampes seront
installées au-dessus des mannequins de
cire lorsque le visiteur passera en
dessous un contenu multimédia sera
envoyé sur l'appareil aucune
manipulation ne sera nécessaire cette
technologie est encore en développement
pour l'instant les envois de données ne
fonctionnent que dans un sens les
ingénieurs espèrent bien à long terme
réussir à faire des échanges ce qui
permettrait notamment d'imaginer une
utilisation pour le web pourquoi pas en
lieu et place du Wii